we've all got our addictions we've all
got our routines mine is to rush to work
make some coffee and go online a little
bit on a desktop up it on my phone
over the morning I give away gigabytes
of information about myself
and I give it without being asked this
is my name this is where I live this is
me on Twitter these are my photos all
this I share out of habit I guess it's
also part of the routine some might call
it an addiction but there is a lot I
share without knowing it and so do you
people making the web every day
encouraged us to share more buy more
click more like more and then sell
information about what we do every day
the technology to do this gets better
and easier and the amount of money being
made from our data increases it's an
industry making hundreds of billions of
dollars from what they know about us but
what do we know about them this is a
start of a documentary series that will
answer this question if you share data
with us we'll show you what the web
knows about you so let's explore
together what this industry is what it's
doing and what you and I need to know
let's track the trackers together
you